coupure la relance de l'enquêté sur la
disparition de la petite estelle c'était
il ya dix mois nouvelle opération de
grande envergure aujourd'hui deux à
trois cents familles vont traitantes
rendre compte être entendu dans les
trois jours qui viennent christelle
bertrand sylvain doba sur place
rassemblés pour la deuxième fois cette
centaine de policiers est là pour
auditionner 300 familles en trois jours
depuis la disparition de la petite
estelle mouzin le 9 janvier 2003 les
enquêteurs n'ont aucune trace de
l'enfant d'une première vague
d'auditions en juin dernier était
ressorti un portrait robot dressé par
une copine d'école qui aurait été
importunée par un homme
trois semaines avant la disparition
d'estelle qualifié d'important ce témoin
est toujours introuvable
les portraits-robots reste d'actualité
comme il ya un certain nombre d'autres
pistes qui restent d'actualité pour
lesquels nous nous exprimons pas
directement
ce qu'il faut retenir c'est qu'il ya le
maximum de moyens possibles qui est mise
en oeuvre dans cette affaire pour
parvenir à la soupçonner raviver les
mémoires et traquer le moindre indice
les enquêteurs gardent espoir autant que
les habitants continuent leur enquête
et puis
peut-être qu'ils trouveront quelque
chose un jour où l'on ne sait pas un
seul petit détail pourrait permettre de
faire avancer l'enquêté
c'est pour cela que les policiers vont
interroger la population des villages
voisins de guermantes